[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في اخبار الساعه من
العربيه نستعرض معكم ابرز المستجدات وفي
العناوين
معارك عنيفه في باخموت الصين تخطط لتسليح
روسيا وبوتين يتعهد بتعزيز الثالث النووي
بعد اطلاق سته صواريخ من القطاع غارات
الاسرائيليه تستهدف مواقع عسكريه تابعه
للفصائل في غزه
الكاميرا العربيه تصد اوضاع الاطفال
الناجين من الزلزال بمشفى السلام في شمال
سوريا
وثيقه سريه تظهر مخاوف استخبارات الحرس
الثوري الايراني من اتساع رقعه الاحتجاجات
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا اليوم تتم العمليه
العسكريه الروسيه في اوكرانيا عامها الاول
فيما تستمر المعارك الداميه ويحاول الجيش
الروسي بس سيطره على المناطق الاوكرانيه
بينما تتلقى الدعم اللوجستيه والعسكريه
الغربي في مواجهه الدب الروسي وعرض بكين
في موسكو رؤيتها لتسويه سياسيه لنزاع في
اوكرانيا فيما ردد الامير العام المتحده
للمنظمه الدوليه بالعمليه العسكريه
الروسيه في اوكرانيا واصفا اياها بانها
اهانه للضمير الجماعي
خلال احتفالات يوم المدافع عن الوطن تعاهد
الرئيس الروسي فاديمير بوتين بتعزيز
التالوث النووي لروسيا في اشاره منه الى
قوه عسكريه قادره على اطلاق ثلاثه انواع
من الاسلحه النوويه مؤكدا مواصله روسيا
انتاج انظمه كنزال التي تفوق سرعتها سرعه
الصوت والبدء بنشر صواريخ زيركون التي
تطلق من البحر
كما كان الوضع من قبل سوف نلوي اهتماما
متزايدا لتقويه الثالث النووي وسنواصل
الانتاج الضخم لانظمه الكنجال الجويه التي
تفوق سرعتها سرعه الصوت ومن البحر سنبدا
في الامداد بكميات كبيره من صواريخ سيركون
اتهم السفير الروسي لدى الامم المتحده
فاسيلين الغرب بانه مستعد لتضحيه
باوكرانيا وبالعالم النام من اجل الحاق
الهزيمه في روسيا وقال السفير في اجتماع
خاص الجمعيه العامه الامم المتحده ان دول
الغرب ترغب في الحاق الهزيمه بروسيا بشتى
الطرق الممكنه مشيرا الى استعداد هذه
الدول في هذا الاطار ليس فقط لتضحيه
باوكرانيا بل لاغراق العالم باسره في
الحرب
في هزيمه روسيا باي طريقه ممكنه لا يمكنهم
فقط التضحيه باوكرانيا فهم مستعدون لاغراق
العالم باسره في هاويه الحرب
كشفت وراء ان اداره رئيس الامريكي
تعتقد انها تبين ان الصين تخطط لتقديم
اسلحه الى روسيا من اجل دعم حربها في
اوكرانيا
الى انه في الاسابيع الاخيره حصلت دول
الغربي على معلومات الاستخباراتيه تفيد
بان قد تنهي قيودها السابقه التي فرضتها
على امدادات الاسلحه الى روسيا مضيفه ان
عددا من المسؤولين حذروا من انبيكين كانت
حاذيره في السابق في حصر دعمها على
المساعده الماليه ومشتريات النفط وان
موقفها الان يتغير وفقا للصحيفه وتصدم
مساعي روسيا لتشكيل التحالف جديد يضم
الهندا والصين بعقبات عده ابرزها الخلافات
التي تحكم علاقات البلدين منذ عقود صحيفه
في وجه هذا التحالف وموقف كلا البلدين منه
نتابع
هذه ليست الجبهه الوحيده التي يريد بوتين
تخطي عقباتها فجبهه لخلق وجمع الحلفاء
ليست موهبه الطريق كما تقول التصريحات
القادمه من الشرق
مدفوعه بتعقد الموقف في حرب اوكرانيا تسعى
موسكو الى تشكيل تحالف يضم الصين والهند
سعي تقيده العلاقات المتازمه بين القوتين
العالميتين بسبب الصراع الحدودي المستمر
بينهما منذ عقود
الصين تريد ان تظل روسيا الى جانبها من
اجل عالم متعدد الاقطاب بينما تحاول الهند
امساك العصا من المنتصف
هذه الحقبه ليست وقتا للحرب فالديمقراطيه
والحوار والدبلوماسيه هي سبل المضي قدما
بكين ومنذ ان بدات روسيا حربها على
اوكرانيا قدمت دعما اقتصاديا ودبلوماسيا
حاسما لموسكو واشترت منتجات الطاقه
الروسيه واتهمت واشنطن والنيتو بتهيئه
الظروف التي ادت الى الغزو الروسي
وفقا لصحيفه وول ستريت جورنال فان مخاوف
القياده الصينيه تتزايد جراء الدعم
العسكري الغربي لاوكرانيا والذي سيضعف
روسيا شريكها السياسي الرئيسي
وتشير سجلات الجمارك الروسيه هذا الشهر
الى ان الصين تقوم في المقابل بشحن معدات
الملاحه وتكنولوجيا التشويش وقطع غيار
المقاتلات الى روسيا ومن
نود ان نؤكد مره اخرى على ان الشراكه
الاستراتيجيه بين روسيا والصين لم توجه
ابدا ضد طرف ثالث وايضا لا تخضع للتدخل
والاستفزاز من قبل اي طرف ثالث والاكثر من
ذلك لن يطغى عليها الاكراه والضغط من
اطراف ثالثه
تقول الصحيفه ان مقاومه اوكرانيا القويه
في ساحه المعركه دفعت بكين الى اعاده
التفكير وجعلها اكثر ميلا للضغط من اجل
وقف اطلاق النار لمنع المزيد من
الانتكاسات الروسيه او حتى هزيمه على نطاق
واسع تفكير قد يضع حدا للحرب وتداعياتها
وصل رئيس الوزراء الاسباني الى العاصمه
الاوكرانيه قبل يوم من ذكرى اندلاع الحرب
الروسيه حيث سيلتقي بالرئيس
بحسب بيان للمكتب الصحفي لمجلس الوزراء
الاسباني واستقبل سانشيز من قبل نائب وزير
خارج الاوكراني
عفوا
مشاهدينا تنضم الينا مراسله العربيه كاتيا
اذا خطاب بوتين الاخيران حمل رسائل قويه
للداخل الروسي فضلا عن رسائل خارجيه دعينا
نبدا بالمستوى الداخلي كيف كانت اصداء هذه
الخطابين
مرحبا احمد بالفعل لليوم الثالث على
التوالي كنا نشهد خطابات للرئيس الروسي
طبعا هي اولا كانت منذ يومين موجهه الى
جمعيه الفيدراليه واليوم هي بمناسبه عيد
المدافع على الوطن كان هناك طبعا جزء كبير
موجه للداخل الروسي لتوضيح ان العمليه
العسكريه واثارها من العقوبات التي فرضت
على روسيا لم تؤثر على
المواطن الروسي من جهه وهي تاتي لطمانه
المواطن الروسيه طبعا ولكن حقيقه هناك كان
ضبابيه بسبب توقعات كانت قد تحدث عنها
الكثير من الخبراء ووسائل الاعلام الروسيه
التي تحدثت عن ان هناك سيكون قرارات او
تصريحات او توقعات لاتخاذ قرارات جديده من
قبل الرئيس الروسي
ولكن هي جاءت طبعا مخيبه قليلا للامال كما
تحدثت بعض الصحف الروسيه التي طبعا مخيبه
للامال بالنسبه مواطن الروسي الذي هو طبعا
يشعر بالقلق بسبب ضبابيه الموقف حتى الان
لان الوضع حتى الان في روسيا هو ما يشابه
قليلا وضع الحرب البارده انذاك عدم وجود
حتى الان وضوح في متى ستنتهي هذه العمليه
العسكريه لرفع الحصار او رفع العقوبات
التي تاثرت بشكل مباشر على المواطن الروسي
من جهه ومن جهه تانيه كان هناك التفاف
طبعا يوم امس خلال الاحتفال الذي شهدته
العاصمه الروسيه موسكو وشارك به بكلمه
مصغره الرئيس الروسي بنفسه كان هناك ايضا
التفاف من المواطنين الروسي الذين طبعا
توجهوا للاحتفال بذكرى عن مدافع عن الوطن
وطبعا هي تصادف ايضا
بقبيل الذكرى السنويه لانطلاق العمليه
العسكريه الروسيه الذي سيكون يوم غد في
هذا السياق يعني هل سجلت اي مواقف او ردود
فعل من قبل المعارضه الروسيه على ما جاء
في حديث بوتين
احمد المعارضه الروسيه والتي هي اغلبها
كانت قد غادرت البلاد
او السنه الماضيه كانت قد غارت غادرت
البلاد معظم المعارضه البارزه في روسيا
طبعا سواء كانت من رجال الاعمال او حتى
الاعلام الروسي المعارض تم طبعا معظمه تم
اغلاقه هنا في موسكو بسبب كما تحدثت موسكو
انها الاعلام الروسي المعارض يقوم
بالحديث بشكل مخالف للاعلام او للتصريحات
الرسميه والتي تسيء بالدرجه الاولى الى
الجيش الروسي وهذا يخالف القانون الروسي
بالاضافه لذلك من الرجال الاعمال او
المعارضه هي اغلبها خارج روسيا طبعا
الكثير كان هناك من دعوات من قبل
النواب مجلس الدوما الى
مصادره ممتلكات هؤلاء المعارضه او
المعارضه التي طبعا هي تعتبر بالخائنه
لروسيا بعد خرو
ومعارضتها طبعا العمليه العسكريه الروسيه
في اوكرانيا
على القرار انه قرار يؤكد الحاجه الى سلام
شامل وعادل ودائم سلام يضمن سياده
اوكرانيا وسلامه اراضيها وينهي العدوان
الروسي المستمر
وخلال اجتماع رفيع المستوى في الامم
المتحده شدد وزير الدوله للشؤون الخارجيه
في السويد جان كونستونس على ضروره ضمان
المسائله عن الجرائم التي ارتكبتها روسيا
في اوكرانيا على حد قومه
يجب ضمان المساءله عن الجرائم المرتكبه
كجزء من العدوان الروسي على اوكرانيا
نواصل ادانه انتهاكات روسيا للقانون
الانساني الدولي والقانون الدولي لحقوق
الانسان ان عمليات الاعدام والتعذيب
والعنف والترحيل القصري ليست سوى امثله
قليله على انتهاكات روسيا غير المقبوله
للقانون الدولي
ميدانيا اكدت وزاره الدفاع البريطانيه انه
على مدار اليومين الماضيين استمر القتال
العليف في قطاع باخموت والقت القوات
الاوكرانيه طرق اعاده الامداد مفتوحه يا
الغرب على الرغم من الحصار الروسي والى
الجانب بل الى الجنوب تعرضت بلده مره اخرى
لقصف عنيف وتوقعت دفاع البريطانيه استعداد
روسيا لمحاوله هجوميه اخرى في المنطقه رغم
هجماتها السابقه التي بالفشل واضافت انه
من المحتمل ان المجموعه الشرقيه للقوات
الروسيه لا تزال مسؤوله عن عمليه فوردار
مؤكده انه من غير المرجح ان يكون لدى قائد
المجموعه رستم برادوف قوه ضاربه قادره على
تحقيق اختراق
هذا هو حضرت وزاره في الدفاع الروسيه من
ان سلطتكيف تعد للقيام باستفزاز مسلح
قريبا يستهدف جمهوريه ترانزيستيريا
الانفصاليه ستنفذه وحدات من الجيش
الاوكراني وقالت الدفاع الروسيه في بيان
ان هجوم الروسيا مزعوما ينطلق من اراد
سيتم اتخاده ذريعه للعدوان الاوكراني
واوضح البيان انه من المخطط ان يرتدي
المخربون الاوكرانيون المشاركون في مسرحيه
الهجوم الزي العسكريه الخاصه بالقوات
المسلحه الروسيه
محتدمه في الشرق الاوكراني ما هي ابرز
ملامح الوضع الميداني احمد حسن مشاهدتكم
ومتابعتك
نعم اهلا محمد يعني كما اسلفت بالفعل هناك
اشتداد للمعارك في الناحيه الشرقيه في
الجبهه هناك استهداف وتزايد للهجمات
المتواصله من الجانب الروسي تحديدا في
منطقه كوبيانسك في خاركيف التي تم
استهدافها بالامس بصوره مكثفه تتحدث
التقارير عن اربع صواريخ سقطت في المنطقه
واستدفت البنيه التحتيه كذلك ايضا القتال
عنيف بصوره كبيره في منطقتين وبخموت في
مقاطعه الحديث عن ان القوات الروسيه تريد
الحصول على اي مكسب خلال اليومين القادمين
تم الدفع بمزيد من التعزيزات والافراد في
هذه الجبهات كما تقول القياده العسكريه
الاوكرانيه منعا او لاي تقدم تحاول تحاول
القيام به القوات الروسيه القياده
العسكريه تؤكد انه لم يتم رصد تقدم على
اطلاق كل هذه المحاولات تم صدها من قبل
الجيش الاوكراني ايضا كان هناك هجمات
متقاطعه في خرسون ضربات صاروخيه مستمره في
هذه المناطق اذا تحدثنا ايضا عن الضربات
الجويه كان هناك 10 ضربات جويه استهدفت
المنطقه الشرقيه في الجبهه كذلك ايضا هناك
محاولات مستمره من قبل القوات الروسيه
للوصول الى الطريق السريع الذي يصل الى
منطقه
التي تقع في اقليم لوغانسك كل هذه الامور
تقول القياده العسكريه الاوكرانيه انها
على يعني على استعداد تام لمواجهه هذه
الهجمات وهذا الهجوم المستمره الذي تقوده
القوات الروسيه لكنهم يعون ويعرفون بصوره
واضحه ان الروسي يعني يواجهون صعوبات
كبيره في هذه الجبهه ربما هناك حديث عن
نقص للذخائر خلافات سياسيه حتى ان
المواطنون هنا في اوكرانيا يتحدثون عن ان
هذه الخليفه الخلافات تؤثر بصوره واضحه
على هجمات الروسيه ما زال المواطنون ايضا
متخوفون احمد منا يعني الحديث بصوره
مستمره عن ان شيئا قد يحدث خلال ذكرى
الاولى الحربه وربما ما تقوله يعني
القياده العسكريه الروسيه من انه هجوما
اوكرانيا قد يحدث يرون ان في هذا
يعني
سبب في القيام بهجوم روسيا على بعض
المناطق المدنيه في اوكرانيا كما تشاهد من
خلفي هذه المنطقه هي منطقه مدنيه يعني
منطقه ناريه بصوره كبيره هذا المبنى تعرض
للقصف كما تشاهدون جزء كبير منهم مدمر
بصوره واضحه هناك محاولات لاعاده ترميمه
لكن هذا مثال للكثير من المناطق التي يعني
دمرت بصوره كبيره
فيعني منذ امس حتى الان كان هناك حوالي 90
هجوما اكثر من ثلثي هذه الهجمات وقعت في
الجبهه الشرقيه للقتال ما بين القوات
الروسيه والاوكرانيه لذلك الجميع يرى انها
اي هجوم متوقع بصوره كبيره تقوم بها قوات
الروسيه في هذه الايام ربما يكون من هذه
الجبهه خاصه مناطق بخموت
ومقاطع نعم احمد شكرا لك على كل هذه
المعلومات احمد بقعته من خار كيف المفدى
العربيه تحياتي
مؤجل ممرضون واطباء اسوريون نحو عاطفتهم
جانبا الاهتمام بالجرحى الذين تدفقوا
للمشافي عقب زلزال في مقابله خاصه العربيه
تحدثت ممرضه في احدى مشافي حارم في ادلب
عن هول الامارات وعن تحولها لبعض الاطفال
في المشفى
وجروح قابله للتضميض وان حفرت بعقولهم
نالوا الفرصه الثانيه اطفال اخرجوا من تحت
الانقاض ليفترشوا اسره احد مشافي حارم في
ريف ادلب هؤلاء يرون بمن يعاملهم من
ممرضات حضن ام فقدوها او اخفي عنهم مصيرها
في عندي مريضه اسمها جنان جنان جنيد هي من
اطفال اللي طلعت من تحت الانقاض هاي جنان
عندي اياها يعني
خط الدفاع الاول في الكارثه هذه المره
تشاركته مجموعتان ففي وقت كان عناصر الخوض
البيضاء منتشرين بين الانقاض يتتبعون
اطراف خيطان علهم يجدون صوتا هنا او يدا
هناك تلتمس من ياخذ بها كان الاطباء وطاقم
التمريض على قله عناصره يهرعون من زاويه
الى اخرى لمحاوله انقاذ من ياتهم بعضهم
لفظ انفاسه الاخيره على مداخل المشافي
واخرون على ايديهم على واتعبي يجيبوا لي
الطفل فانا عم باخذه عم بيقولوا لي عايش
عايش فبجي
بيكون انفاسه الاخيره يعني ما بعرف لانه
انا فقدت رفيقتي هون
راحت الضحايا الزلزال كانت ممرضه معنا
جابوا لنا رئيس المشفى فنحني عرفناه من
استشهد الله يرحمه فتركناه والتفتنا لغيره
مات الله يرحمه ففي عالم لسه لسا عايشه
لسه بتديانا فنحن رحنا لهنيك الحزن المؤجل
رافق صرخه الخذلان فالاخيره باتت مالوفه
في سوريا وسقلتها حرب ممتده منذ 12 عاما
لتكمل عليها كارثه راح ضحيتها الالاف في
كل زاويه منها هناك من يبكي الفقد ويقول
لو كان هناك امكانيات او مساعدات لربما من
ابكيه ظل موجودا الارض خزلتنا
الحرب خزنتنا
كل الدنيا خذلتنا ما حدا اجا انقاذ كان
الدفاع المدني بالخط الاول
[موسيقى]
ما حدا اجانا من برا فخلاص وقفت وقف الصوت
الاصوات اللي نزلنا نسمعه تحت الانقاذ
ساعتين ثلاثه كان ما كان بالاصوات
الذي لا تزال غالبيه المستشفيات في شمال
غرب سوريا تكافح لعلاج المصابين كشف رئيس
قسم التخدير في مستشفى الشفاء في ادلب
احمد خطيب كشف ان غالبيه المصابين افرازال
كانت حالتهم خطيره اضافه الى تسجيل حالات
كثيره بمتلازمه العرس فيما كشفت عمات طفله
تدعى سندس اصيبت
بمتلازمه الهرس في القدمين ان المستشفى
يعمل على علاجها لتجنب تفاقم حالتها طبعا
معظم مشاكل
من الاصابات عدد الاصابات كان ضخم جدا
يعني
كان عدد اصابات هائل
طبعا نحن هون مشفىنا مشفى شفاء في ادلب
عملنا استنفار كامل الكادر بشكل كامل طبعا
معظم الاصابات كانت اصابات
خطيره واصابات مي سهله معظم الاصابات كانت
اصابات حرس بسبب انضغاط شديد في عالم
طلعهم تحت الانقاذ بعد عشر ساعات في عالم
بعد 24 ساعه في عالم بعد 48 ساعه هدول
فتره تضلوا فاتحت الانقاض كلياتها عده
لهرس واديت الارتفاع بوتاسيوم واديت
الاضطراب شوارد الجسم
[موسيقى]
من مشفى الشفاء في ادلب ينضم الينا مراسله
العربيه محمد الاشقر اهلا بك محمد وكيف
يمكن ان تصف لنا حالا الاطفال الناجين في
مستشفيات في مشافي شمال سوريا على خلفيه
هذا الزلزال بحسب مشاهدتك
نعم يعني في الحقيقه
متلازمه الهرس شبح جديد يلاحق الاطفال
الناجين هنا في عموم مناطق شمال الغرب
سوريا هناك العديد من الاصابات بهذه المرض
وهناك العديد من الاطفال المهددين ببطر
الاطراف نتيجه هذه
الاصابات طبعا نحن الان في مشفى الشفاء
كان من المفترض ان ندخل الى جناح الاطفال
هنا في هذا المشفى ولكن قبل اجراء عمليه
البث هذه لاحظنا ان
الحاله النفسيه للاطفال لا تسمح بتصويرهم
الان يعني الاطفال بصراحه بحاله يرفوا
بحاله يرثى لها بحاله مزريه جدا نفسيا
وجسديا طبعا
الاصابات يعني كثيره في فئه الاطفال هناك
يعني
اخرى يعني غير جسديه وهي اصابه العائله
هناك العديد من الاطفال حقيقه فقدوا اهلهم
والى حد هذه اللحظه لا يعلمون انهم فقدوا
اهلهم ولكن يعلمون انهم من الممكن ان ان
يفقدوا اطرافهم نتيجه هذه الاصابات يعني
حقيقه
الالام التي يشعر بها صعبه جدا
هناك العديد من الاصابات التي تحتاج
لاجهزه طبيه متطوره الى حد هذه
رعايه هؤلاء الاطفال هل تتم بصوره فرديه
ام من هناك جهات او منظمات يمكن ان تقدم
المزيد من الدعم لهم
نعم يعني في الحقيقه الوضع الطبي هنا في
عموم شمال غرب سوريا ودعني اتحدث هنا في
مشفى الشفاء يعني من ناحيه الاجهزه الطبيه
هناك
عجز في موضوع الاجهزه الطبيه وخصوصا في
موضوع الاجهزه المتعلقه بامراض الكلى وهذا
يعني وهذا الاختصاص يعني
هو الاكثر
طلبا هنا بعد حادثه الزلزال الذي ضربت
المنطقه خصوصا لمصابين متلازمه الهرس طبعا
هناك عجز في موضوع الاجهزه اما بالنسبه
لعمل المنظمات
المنظمات تاتي الى الى المشافي تقدم بعض
الهدايا للاطفال الهدايا
العينيه او الهدايا الرمزيه للاطفال اما
من الناحيه الطبيه فهناك عجز في الحقيقه
من ناحيه الاجهزه الطبيه هناك مناشدات
تطلق من شمال غ لا يزال الاطباء هنا في
شمال غرب سوريا يطلقون المناشدات للخارج
بالاسراع بادخال الاجهزه الطبيه لانقاذ ما
يمكن انقاذه محمد ذكرت ايضا الاطفال في
بدايه حديثك ان الاثار النفسيه على هؤلاء
الاطفال كبيره جدا هل يتواجد او يتوفر
اطباء نفسيون في هذه المناطق المتضرره
البعض من
الاطباء النفسيين ويعني المرشدين النفسيين
يحاولون
علاج هؤلاء الاطفال ولكن في الوضع الحالي
الهم الاكبر للفريق الطبي في عموم شمال
غرب سوريا هو انقاذ الاطفال حاليا نتيجه
الاصابات الخطره اعداد الاصابات الخطيره
مرتفعه جدا
وفي المرحله التاليه سيبدا ستبدا مرحله
العلاج النفسي طبعا هناك ناحيتين مؤثرتين
بالاطفال الناحيه الاولى هي من هول المشهد
من هول اللحظه التي وقع فيها الزلزال
والناحيه الثانيه هي ان هؤلاء الاطفال
حقيقه الى حد هذه اللحظه لا يعلمون انهم
فقدوا زويهم سواء كان الاب او الام او حتى
الاخوه يعني نلاحظ ان اغلب المرافقين هنا
في المشفى له
الاطفال اطفالهم من اقرباء العمه او
الخاله او العم او الخال من النادر انتجت
الام مع ابنها او الاب مع ابنه او ابنته
طيب محمد يعني هذه المشاهدات كانت من ادلب
حيث تتواجد لكن ماذا عن مناطق النظام هل
يبدو الحال مختلفا في مستشفياتها هناك
نعم يعني في الحقيقه حجم يختلف حجم
الكارثه ما بين
مناطق شمال غرب سوريا ومناطق
سيطره قوات النظام بحسب ما وصلنا ان هناك
العديد من الاصابات ايضا وصلت الى مشافي
مشافي المنطقه التي يسيطر عليها النظام
طبعا هناك مساعدات وصلت الى الى مناطق
سيطره النظام ايضا هناك مناشدات لايصال
اجهزه للنظام ولكن هناك مناشدات لمراقبه
سير عمليه
توزيع هذه المساعدات التي وصلت يعني الحال
ربما في مناطق سيطره النظام يعني ساوي
ايضا وكارثه من الناحيه الطبيه وحتى من
الناحيه الانسانيه محمد شكرا لك بمشفى
الشفاء في ادلب كنت معنا مراسل العربيه
الاشقر اذا مشاهدينا هذه الصور حصريه
لقناه العربيه ترصد فيها اوضاع الاطفال
الناجي من الزلزال في مشفى السلام في ادلب
وذلك على في عقاب الجزائر المدمر الذي طال
المناطق في شمال سوريا وجنوب تركيا في
السادس من فبراير الماضي وقد ارتفعت اعداد
القتلى حتى الان في سوريا لقرابه 7000
قتيل اذا هذه الصور حصريه للعربيه من ادلب
ترصد اوضاع الاطفال الناجيين من الزلزال
في مشفى السلام
من شمال سوريا مشاهدينا الى جنوب تركيا
حيث يعيش الاف المنكوبين ظروفا صعبه داخل
المخيمات بعد ان كانوا يلعبون ببيوت تحولت
فجاه الى ركام بفعل زلزال المدمر الذي ضرب
المنطقه مفرد العربيه مشاهدين عبد القادر
خربوش رافق يوميات الناجين من الزلزال
اكبر المناطق تضررا واعد التقرير التالي
هكذا يستيقظ سكان الخيام فيها تاي البرد
الذي ودعهم ليلا هو اول من يستقبلهم نهارا
شوادر ملال موزه عندي خمس اولاد
طلع مناظر جربوا
لم يعد هناك سقف امن في هاتاي انقلبت
الاسقف على رؤوس ساكنيها قتلت منهم الالاف
وشردت الناجين
بعضهم يعود اليها متحصرا والبعض الاخر
باحثا عما يبقيه متصلا بماضيه الجميل
زلزال قوي ماذا ابدا ما في ولا بنائي هذا
البنايه الموجودين رايحين
لم يبقى لنا هنا اي شيء لا اعلم كيف سنعيش
اني ابني راح
من اسطنبول عليها
من علي تبدو انطاكيا مركز هاتاي متماسكه
ومتمسكه بعراقه تاريخها لكن ما ان تدقق
النظر حتى يتكشف حجم الدمار الذي لحق بها
خلال حدوث الزلزال خرجنا الى الشارع هنا
في الاعلى لم يحدث دمار كبير لكن هناك في
اسفل المدينه تدمرت بالكامل
مع افول الشمس ودفئها الذي يستانس به
الناجون خلال يومهم يحل البرد مجددا
ليسحبهم في ليلهم داخل هذه الخيام
ولانه لم يعد هناك سقف امن في هاتاي نقد
ليالينا تحت سقف هذه السياره ونحن بذلك
اوفر حظا من الاف يفترشون الارض في الخيام
عبد القادر خربوش العربيه
تتواصل اعمال رفع الانقاص في ولايه كهرمان
مرعش حيث حددت السلطات الامنيه الواجب
هدمها بسرعه وكذلك عدد المنازل الجديده
التي سيتم انشاؤها في الولايه نتابع في
مركز ولا كهرمان مرعش تسابق هذه الاليات
الزمن لازاله الاف الاطنان من الركام
والكتل الخرسانيه التي خلفها زلزالان ضربا
هذه الولايه في السادس من فبراير
التقديرات الرسميه تقول ان اكثر من 12 الف
مبنى تضم 60 الف منزل اما دمرت بشكل كامل
او جزئي او تصدعت بشكل كبير لذلك تقرر
هدمها بشكل عاجل في المقابل فان عمليه
اعاده الاعمال ستبدا قريبا اعتبارا من
مارس القادم وقال الرئيس التركي رجب طيب
اردوغان ان هذه الولايه اي كهرمان مرعش
ستشهد بناء اكثر من 45 الف منزل جديد في
عمليه اعاده الاعمار زيدان زنجلو كهرمان
مرعش
ضرب زلزال بقوه 6 درجات فاصله ثمانيه شرطه
جكستان صباح اليوم بحسب ما اعلنت الهيئه
المسح الجيولوجيه الامريكيه وقالت الهيئه
الزلزال يقع على عمق 20 كم فاصل خمسه
وحددت الهيئه مركز زلزال في جورنو وهي
منطقه تتمتع بحكم شبه ذاتي وتقع في شرق
تاجكستان على الحدود مع كل من افغانستان
والصين
نشاطنا مستمره مشاهدينا وفيها بعد الفاصل
السلطه الفلسطينيه تلغي محادثات مع
مسؤولين اسرائيليين على خلفيه العمليه
العسكريه في نابلس
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا من جديد شنا الجيش
الاسرائيلي صباح اليوم مباراه استهدفت
مواقع لحركه حماس في قطاع غزه قال الجيش
انها مواقع لانتاج الاسلحه وكذا مجمع
عسكريا اخر الغارات الاسرائيليه مشاهدينا
جاءت ردا على اطلاق صواريخ فجر اليوم قطاع
باتجاه اسرائيل ونقلت وكاله الانباء
الفرنسيه عن شهود عيان ان ما لا يقل عن
ثمانيه صواريخ اطلقت من القطاع باتجاه
اسرائيل بينما اعلن الجيش الاسرائيلي رصد
سته صواريخ اعترضت منظومه القبه الحديديه
خمسه منها وسقط صاروخ السادس في منطقه غير
ماهوله وياتي على التصعيد غداه عمليه
عسكريه نفذها جيش الاسرائيلي في مدينه
نابلس شمال الضفه الغربيه المحتله قتل
خلالها 11 فلسطينيا واصيب اكثر من 80
اخرين بالرصاص الحي بحسب وزاره الصحه
الفلسطينيه
في سياق هذا التوتر افاد وراسه العربي بان
القوات الاسرائيليه اطلقت النار على سيده
فلسطينيه قرب مستوطنه معالي ادومي شرق
القدس بذريعه نيتها تنفيذه عمليه الطان
من حدود قطاع غزه المشاهدين ينضم الينا
العربيه زياد حلبي اهلا بك زياد وكيف كانت
داعيات الغارات الاسرائيليه التي شنت
اليوم على قطاع غزه
التوتر يبقى سيدا للموقف على حدود قطاع
غزه هناك حاله تاهب اسرائيليه لجهه النشاط
المقاتلات في الاجواء بين الحين والاخر
وبالاضافه طبعا الى بطاريات القبه
الحديديه المنتشره في اكثر من مكان في هذه
المنطقه تحسبا لاي امر ولكن التقدير ربما
في خلال الساعات الاخيره بان هذا التبادل
للقصف ما بين الصواريخ الفلسطينيه
والغارات الاسرائيليه وصل الى نهايته لهذا
اليوم لكن لا يعني الامر بان التصعيد وصل
الى نهايته ابدا التقديرات بان هذا
التبادل المتقطع للقصف عمليا وبسبب
التصعيد النوعي الحاصل في الضفه الغربيه
المحتله ومن ثم الان سنرى المزيد من
العمليات الفرديه ايضا ستعيد الكره الى
هذه الجبهه مره اخرى بم هذه المعادله باتت
منذ عامين التي نراها دائما تصعيد نوعي في
شمال الضفه الغربيه المحتله رايناه بالامس
في نابلس عمليا جاء الرد بسته صواريخ
اعترض خمسه منها بواسطه بطاريات القبه
الحديديه وبعد ذلك غارات اسرائيليه صباح
هذا اليوم على مواقع في قطاع غزه ومن ثم
عمليه في القدس الشرقيه المحتله بمعنى هذا
الترابط بات نوعا ما متماسكا منذ سنتين
ولكن كل ذلك زياد يدفع ايضا بالتساؤل حول
افاق الرد الاسرائيلي المتوقع والمد الذي
يمكن ان تصل اليه الحكومه الاسرائيليه
الجديده الحاليه في تعاطيها مع
الفلسطينيين في هذه الازمه
طبعا هناك انتقادات للحكومه اليمنيه
الخالصه في اسرائيل
عمليا لانها يعني تبدو فيما يخص قطاع غزه
بانها تتابع عمليا ما يحدث في العشرين
عاما الاخيره من حيث الردود على الصواريخ
بغارات محدوده وما الى ذلك هناك انتقادات
للحكومه في اسرائيل لكن بدون ان شك هناك
بناء تراكمي انجاز التعبير للتصعيد بمعنى
الحديث الاسرائيلي متواتر ولا ينقطع عن ان
منشده من تصعيد الان هو فقط تمهيد لما قد
نشهده من تصعيد نوعي وربما يكون كبيرا في
شهر رمضان عمليا هكذا يدعي الاسرائيليون
بان فرص اندلاع مواجهه شامله وحتى حرب
جديده على قطاع غزه تبدو واقعيه
للغايه عمليا
اعلام الاسرائيليه بان السلطه الفلسطينيه
الغت محادثات مع مسؤولين اسرائيليين كبار
على خلفيه العمليه العسكريه الاسرائيليه
في مدينه نابلس امس الاربعاء والتي اسفرت
عن مقتل احد عشر فلسطينيه وبحسن ما ذكرت
القناه الثانيه عشر الاسرائيليه فان
المحادثات كانت مقرره استكمالا لمحادثات
الماضي مشيره الى ان المسؤولين
الاسرائيليين ونظرائهم
كانوا قد تواصلوا بالفعل الى استنتاجات
وتفاهمات لتهدئه الاوضاع قبل حلول شهر
رمضان الا ان المحادثات توقفت بعد هذه
العمليه
على وثيقه تظهر مخاوف استخبارات الحرس
الثوري الايراني من احتمال توزع
الاحتجاجات العامه في البلاد الى عمال
صناعه السيارات وتصف الوثيقه المطالب
المعيشه العمال بالجشع وطلب المزيد
نشره مستمره مشاهدينا وفيها بعد الفاصل
استدعاء
في تحقيق هجوم الكابيتون
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا من جديد في قضيه الهجوم
على ايفانكا ابنه الرئيس السابق دونالد
ترامبا وصهره من قبل المستشار الخاص
لادلاء بشهادتهما امام هيئه محلفين
فيدراليه كبرى حول جهد ترامب بقاء في
السلطه بعد خساره انتخابات عام 2020 ودوره
في الهجوم على
يناير وفقا لما ذكره شخصان تم اطلاعه مع
الامر لصحيفه نيويورك تايمز الامريكيه
كشفت وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه عن صوره
سيلفي التقطها طيار طائره تجسس الامريكيه
من طراز جو اثنين حيث يظهر فيها من طاب
التجسس الصيني قبل اسقاطه قباله سواحل
كما اشار تقرير اشرته صحيفه
صوره سيلفي مع المنطاد هذا وكانت الولايات
المتحده خلال الايام الماضيه انتشرت اجزاء
كبيره من اجهزه الاستشعار والالكترونيات
كانت مرفقه بالمنطاد الصيني الذي اسقط في
اوائل فبراير حسبما افاد الجيش الامريكي
الحرب في افغانستان مشاهدينا ادت الى
اعاقه الملايين من الشعب الافغاني وما
زالت اله فطر الاعضاء تعمل في الافغان
جراء الالغام الارضيه التي تم زرعها خلال
السنوات الحرب العربيه تستطلع وضع معاقين
حروب الكثيرين في افغانستان
نور اغا جندي سابق فقد رجليه جراء انفجار
قنبله وسط العاصمه كابول قبل اربع سنوات
ومنذ ذلك الوقت يستخدم رجلين صناعيتين
يقول انه لرداءه الصنع واجه مشاكل كثيره
خلال هذه المده طبق الان هنا للحصول على
رجلين صناعيتين جديدتين وقد صنعوهما لي
امل ان تكون مرحه
محمد خان هو الثاني الذي فقد رجليه منذ
اربعين عاما يقول ان العيش صعب بالنسبه
لذوي الاعاقات وان استخدام هذه الارجل
المصنوعه ليس مريحا على الاطلاق
لاول مره ومنذ اربعه اشهر حصلت على رجلين
صناعيتين مريحتين الى حد ما حيث استطيع
المشي فيهما ساعه او ساعتين واستطيع ان
اقوم فيها بحياتي على الرغم من وجود وزاره
مستقله تعنى بورثه اهالي الضحايا والارامل
والمصابين فانه لا توجد احصائيات دقيقه
لعدد من فقدوا اطرافهم في افغانستان في
وقت تفيد مسوحات اجرتها جهات مستقله بان
عددهم ثلاثه ملايين نحن الى هذا الوقت
سجلنا
55,100 الف شخص معاق وتستمر
التسجيل
بحسب المعاقين فان الاشخاص ذوي الاعاقه
يحتاجون بشكل خاص الى الدعم المالي
والنفسي مضيفين انه يجب على منظمات
الاغاثه الدوليه
مساعدتهم دون انقطاع
وفقا لبحث اجرتهم مؤسسه اسيا يوجد في
افغانستان اكبر عدد من الاشخاص ذوي
الاعاقه في العالم يتشاركون بنوع واحد من
الاعاقه نتيجه لاكثر من اربعه عقود من
الحروب والالغام الارضيه والذخائر غير
المنفجره التي خلفتها الحرب عبد الانادر
العربيه كابول
بعض سلسله من الانقطاعات المتكرره في
التقويم الدراسي بدا الجلسات امتحانات
التلاميذ مرحله الاساس في السودان وبرغم
اصرار لجنه المعلمين على مواصله الاضراب
العمليه التعليميه تعاني هذا لسان حال
المدارس في السودان
هنا في ولايه الخرطوم بدا الطلاب جلسات
الامتحانات روميسرا لجنه المعلمين بمواصله
الاضراب الا ان بعض المعلمين قرروا مساعده
التلاميذ دون المساس بمطالبهم نحن هسه
حاليا نزلنا المدارس مع ابنائنا لانه
المدار هي اصبحوا التلاميذ اصبحوا
راجعين يمشوا راجعين وقفنا معاهم نزلتين
الامتحانات امتحناهم وما زلنا على رابدين
على الجمر على حقنا يعني ما متنازلين
معاناه الاباء والامهات ليست منحصره في
تزعزع العام الدراسي فقط بل امتدت لقيامهم
بدوري المعلم في التدريس والمراجعه لا
يمكن
تقفل المدرسه انت بتطالب بحقوقك بطرق
شرقيه لكن كونه المدرسه تقفل الضرر اكبر
ربما انه العام يتضرر والتعليم ده اهم
حاجه في اي دوله تقدم الرغيه والتطور كله
على التعليم العام
رغم الابتسامه التي تبدو على وجوه هؤلاء
التلاميذ الا انهم المتضرر الاول من اضراب
ينفذه عدد من المعلمين اضراب قد يسبب فشل
او ضياع العام الدراسي
لجنه المعلمين السودانيه تقول ان تعليق
العام الدراسي ليس في مصلحه احد لكنهم
حريصون على حقوقهم ولن يتراجعوا عن
مطالبهم تعطيل العام الدراسي كارثه
ماديين يدينا والله بيضاء
لحكومه الامر الواقعي دي والله ما ادري لا
يؤدينا عشان ننقذ العمل الدراسي ده لكن
والله كمان يعني
يعني نحن مشينا خطوه تجاهك تعال خطوات
تجاهنا عشان نقدر نغز العمل دراسي
المخاوف لا تزال قائمه من انهيار التفاهم
بين لجنه المعلمين والسلطات المعنيه في
الدوله حال اخفاق الاخيره في تلبيه
المطالب التي تم الاتفاق عليها ما يجعل
مستقبل التلاميذ محاطا بمخاطر لا يملكون
ردها سالم الهاشمي العربيه الخرطوم
اذا مشاهدينا اعشاك مواطنوا ولايه جنوب
كردفان في السودان من ترد الاوضاع الامنيه
في الولايه وطالب الحكومه بتدخل لايقاف
النهب والسرقات وحوادث القط المتكرره رغم
اعلان الطوارئ في الولايه قبل اكثر من 20
يوما ونسي قوه مشتركه لفرض الامن ووضع حد
للجرائم المتكرره في هذه الولايه
تبدو ولايه جنوب كردفان وهي محاطه بسلسله
من الجبال امنه لكن مواطنين عاصمتها
كادوغلي يشكون من فلتان امني تمثل في نهب
للممتلكات وتكرار حوادث القتل بالاضافه
لكثافه حمل السلاح بصوره ملفته الوضع
العملي في
بالتحديد عموما سيء جدا ولكن الامنيه في
الغياب تام تماما الوضع الامني وضع متردد
للغايه يعني ما في زول بيضمن انه هو يكون
ماشي في الشارع شايل تليفون كبير ولا سائل
جلوس في جيبه ويضمن انه يوصل بيته ما يمر
يوم الا هناك قتيل هناك نهب هناك يعني
جرائم كثيره جدا
الصراع القبلي وقطع الطرق اقلق الاهالي
واثر على الاسواق الشعبيه منعكس سلبا على
حياتهم
المواطنون هنا ينشدون الامن اكثر من
اهتمامهم بلقمه العيش ويبدو عليهم الارهاق
وتكسو ملامحهم الحيره
لو طلعت مشيت مشوار ابد مشوار في الحته
الفلانيه هيحصل لي كده او القى المشكله
لكده
الكاتيل ناهي
اطالب شارع هنا في جنوب كردفان كثيره جدا
في مقدمتها الملف الامني اذ يشكو
المواطنون من تفلتات امنيه متكرره تضع
حكومه الولايه امام تحد لتحقيق اشواقهم
استشعرت الحكومه السودانيه الخطر فدشنت
عمل القوه المشتركه المكونه من القوات
المسلحه الدعم السريع الشرطه وجهاز
المخابرات وجهت بتفعيل قانون الطوارئ بشكل
صارم ويطال المتخاذرين والمتفلتين من
الاجهزه النظاميه مهمه ايضا تجوب بقيه
انحاء الولايه اهدافها القبض على المبلغ
عنهم المجرمين والمتفلتين والمتهمين
بحوادث القتل حتى لو من عشر سنوات هذه
القوه المشتركه تعقد عليها الامال في
توفير الاجابه لسؤال متى تكون كادوبلي
امنه سالم الهاشمي العربيه ولايه جنوب
كردفان
في اليمن دفعت الحرب الحوثيه والحصار على
المدينه عشرات النسوه في تعز الى الانخراط
في سوق العمل وممارسه اعمال شاقه كانت
حكره على الرجال قبل الحرب من اجل اعاله
اسرهم
[موسيقى]
كانها قبر قبر يعني اياك يعني هي عباره عن
بنفس الوقت لحتى لما اقوم اصلي ما فيش نفس
حتى للسكاده والله انني اصلي ولمن والله
العظيم اننا اصلي اللبن ارجو لعيالي علينا
ما كنش الغلا ذا لا غير محد الحرب الغلا
واحنا نخرج ونمرة عجوز
مرهق جدا البحث عن القوت اليومي في
المدينه المحاصره هذه فعلى ارصفه الشوارع
تصف عشرات النسوه بحثا عما يسد الرمق
خصوصا من فقدنا ازواجهن في الحرب
زوجي ماتتوفي معي ثلاثه جهال يعني
اطلب الله على عيالي وتشور تقارير امميه
الى ان اكثر من عشرين مليون شخص في اليمن
اي ما يعادل 70% من اجمالي السكان بحاجه
ماسه للمساعده الانسانيه كم يصعب اذا على
ساكن هذه المدينه الحصول على لقمه العيش
في ظل الحرب والحصار الحوتي فالاسواق هذه
تكتظ بالعديد من الباعه جميعهم يعيشون
الضنك الحياه خصوصا النساء والاطفال الذين
اجبروا على الانخراط في سوق العمل لاعاله
اسرهم هل سعيد العربيه
تعز والان مشاهدينا بقي ان نذكر بابرز
العناوين
معارك عنيفه في باخموت الصين تخطط لتسليح
روسيا وبوتين يتعهد بتعزيز الثالوث النووي
بعد اطلاق سته صواريخ من القطاع غاره
اسرائيليه تستهدف مواقع عسكريه تابعه
للفصائل في غزه
كاميرا العربيه ترصد اوضاع الاطفال
الناجين من الزلزال بمشفى السلام في شمال
سوريا
وثيقه سريه تظهر مخاوف استخبارات الحرس
الثوري الايراني من اتساع رقعه الاحتجاجات
نهايه هذه الساعه الاخباريه مشاهدينا شكرا
حسن المتابعه وفي امان الله
[موسيقى]